bonjour à tous je m'appelle Théo
corbeaulio et dans la vie j'ai trois
passions l'entrepreneuriat la course à
pied en nature et la crème glacée j'ai
parlé avec les équipes de TEDx avant de
venir ici puis m'ont dit que ma
troisième passion vous intéresserait un
peu moins bon je me concentrer sur les
deux premières l'entrepreneuriat et la
course à pied longue distance aussi
appelée
ultra Twer rang
alors oui j'aime monter des montagnes
que ce soit au sens propre en courant ou
au sens figuré l'entrepreneuriat est une
rude mais magnifique ascension
après avoir cofondé deux entreprises
technologiques je suis maintenant
responsable des programmes
d'accompagnement ici à HEC Montréal
j'accompagne cette année 85
entrepreneurs dans l'ascension de leur
montagne entrepreneuriale à eux
le thème de la conférence aujourd'hui et
actes now agit tout de suite je me suis
permis une traduction libre act now
entreprend maintenant je suis convaincu
qu'il est crucial d'entreprendre
maintenant
l'entrepreneuriat elle vend dans les
voiles ces dernières années on entend on
en entend de plus en plus parler et de
façon toujours plus positive il devrait
donc avoir plus d'entrepreneurs
aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait avant et
bien c'est faux selon l'indice
entrepreneurial québécois il y avait
plus d'entrepreneurs en 2009 qu'il y en
a aujourd'hui
ce qui a considérablement augmenté par
contre c'est l'intention
entrepreneuriale bon pour résumer de
plus en plus de gens souhaitent
entreprendre mais de moins en moins le
fond
cette étude recense les entreprises
incorporées je ne définition plus large
de l'entrepreneuriat vous proposer pour
moi un entrepreneur est une personne qui
identifie un problème rassemble des
ressources pour comprendre ce problème
et qui avec une équipe développe une
solution durable pour le régler pour moi
une entreprise est une personne qui par
ses actions mène des changements
positifs dans la société Rosa Parks qui
refuse de céder sa place dans le bus ou
Greta Tomberg qui tous les vendredis
luttent pour le climat sont d'excellents
exemple de leader positif qui transforme
les mentalités et créer des changements
durables
créer une start-up tech et la vendre 5
ans plus tard à l'étranger la plupart du
temps ça enrichit des personnes mais ça
ne transforme pas des sociétés
je suis sûrement influencé par les
bâtisseurs du Québec inc qui sont passés
entre ces murs mais je suis convaincu
que le Québec de demain sera fait de
bâtisseuse et de bâtisseurs qui
développent des solutions long terme et
durables aux enjeux actuels et des
enjeux il y en a le sixième rapport du
GIEC est formel la planète n'a jamais
été dans un aussi mauvais état et j'ai
l'impression que les humains qu'il
habite ils sont pas en pleine forme non
plus santé physique et santé mentale
semble tirer toutes les sonnettes
d'alarme bref aujourd'hui plus que
jamais il est crucial d'entreprendre
tout de suite
assez parlé d'entrepreneuriat et de
choses sérieuses je vous ai parlé de
plusieurs passions en introduction
j'aimerais maintenant vous parler de
crème glacée non pardon de course en
centimes longue distance
dans une histoire en six chapitres je
vais vous partager mon expérience de
coureur et j'espère qu'elle sera vous
inspirer pour peut-être vous donner
envie de vous aussi gravir vos montagnes
ou qui sait d'entreprendre tout de suite
chapitre 1 l'important c'est de
commencer petit j'ai toujours été actif
mais je n'ai jamais vraiment couru je
viens d'une famille de prof de sport
donc j'ai grandi en faisant ce qu'on
fait tous dans les cours de sport un peu
de tout mais surtout du badminton arrivé
au Québec en 2013 moi j'ai dû mettre le
badminton de côté pour me consacrer à
des sports plus québécois Aki James
football j'ai tout essayé avec plus ou
moins de succès début 2014 un ami me dit
et Théo tu es en forme toi pogame de
courir un marathon moi de répondre avec
toute l'intelligence d'un jeune adulte
un marathon ben ouais je suis game je
rentre chez nous j'ouvre mon laptop et
demande à Google combien de kilomètres y
a-t-il dans un marathon
42.2 ouf c'est beaucoup ça donc je suis
pas coureur je sais pas par où commencer
je sais pas comment m'entraîner alors
bah je fais pas grand chose
le temps passe l'événement a lieu dans
un mois je vais quand même courir 17 km
juste pour voir ce que ça fait
mal aux jambes ça fait mal aux jambes me
voici donc sur la ligne de départ du
marathon de Montréal septembre 2014 port
le départ est donné c'est un Théo
heureux qui s'élance mais qui n'a aucune
idée dans quoi il s'embarque je franchis
quand même la ligne d'arrivée 3h49 plus
tard
détruit j'ai eu mal aux jambes pendant
deux mois et j'ai plus couru pendant
deux ans
quatre ans plus tard ce même ami me dit
Théo on a couru 42 km sur le plat
maintenant c'est facile j'ai trouvé
notre prochain défi 50 km de course en
montagne moi bien sûr de répondre ok
donc me voici en août 2018 à stonam dans
les montagnes de Québec prêt à prendre
le départ d'une course de 50 km dans les
montagnes
j'ai franchi la ligne d'arrivée 9h55
plus tard
c'était extrêmement dur mais j'ai pris
du plaisir dans cet effort en nature
j'étais un peu plus entraîné en amont et
j'ai aimé ça me dépasser dans la forêt
québécoise
la pandémie frappe
tout s'arrête j'ai du temps je me mets à
courir plus et je me demande est-ce que
je pourrais courir plus de 50 km
chapitre 2 rêvé grand je m'inscris donc
à un Ultra Trail de 80 km ce défi est
difficile à concevoir et veille en moins
un sentiment particulier et si j'y
arrivais
non tu es au calme toi tu es encore mal
aux jambes de ton marathon de 2014 relax
je télécharge quand même un plan
entraînement gratuit je m'entraîne un
peu plus ça fait maintenant partie de ma
routine j'adore ça septembre 2020 je
suis donc sur la ligne de départ de
l'Ultra Trail arigana du Canada après à
courir 80 km dans les montagnes de
Charlevoix la course se passe à peu près
bien je franchis la ligne d'arrivée et
tout de suite dans ma tête what's next
en courant davantage je me fais un
groupe d'amis coureurs vraiment craqué
je leur demande hey les gars ça existe
tu des courses de plus de 80 km Benoît
un bon ami et coureur aguerri me dit tu
veux courir longtemps Théo
tu regarderas l'échappée belle
je rentre chez moi et c'est le coup de
foudre
l'ultra traversé du massif de Belledonne
150 km de course à pied au travers un
massif rocailleux pour 11500 mètres de
dénivelé positif ce que ça veut dire en
français ça c'est comment une fois le
mot Everest on redescend on le remonte à
moitié et puis on essaye de le
redescendre
une des courses les plus difficiles du
monde chaque année plus de 600 personnes
prennent les deux parts et à peine 300
arrive à l'arrivée bref j'avais mon
grand rêve deux points particuliers à
noter le passage à la Croix de
Belledonne point culminant de la course
à 3000 mètres d'altitude et le col du
mauritan vous voyez la grande courbe là
ça ça veut dire que ça manque très très
raide
chapitre 3 le progrès c'est des efforts
plus du repos ma vie a changé investie
d'une mission j'ai pas le choix de
m'entraîner plus si je ne veux pas
craquer après 50 km avec mes amis on
fait un pronostic ok si je fais un Miss
si je termine cette course sauvage ça
devrait me prendre entre 35 et 40 heures
comment je fais pour m'entraîner à
bouger pendant 40 heures
je vais au travail en courant
aller-retour et le week-end je fais des
fun Atlantes je pars de Montréal à vélo
jusqu'au montagne environnante j'y cours
20 30 km et je reviens à vélo 9 10
heures d'efforts ça fait des bonnes
journées
je lis aussi énormément j'apprends à
quantifier le stress physique que
j'impose à mon corps assez pour
progresser rapidement mais pas trop pour
ne pas exploser en plein vol
je découvre les secrets de la nutrition
je mange pour avoir de l'énergie et
enfin je dors des 8 heures de sommeil
réparatrice bref je connais avec mon
corps
chapitre 4 les relations c'est tout
mes amis experts me donnent leur truc
nutrition gestion du sommeil équipement
eux qui ont été sur le terrain ils
m'aident à faire un plan mes amis mes
parents pardon qui ne comprennent
absolument rien cette histoire folle me
soutiennent ils seront d'ailleurs
présents pour la course ils acceptent
ils acceptent d'être mon clou c'est à
dire mon équipe de soutien ils seront à
des points clés de la course pour me
donner de la nutrition de l'équipement
sec mais surtout des encouragements et
de la tendresse
mon frère accepte d'être mon pays seul
mon accompagnateur le plan c'est qu'il
me rejoigne au kilomètre 70 et quand au
kilomètre 80 et qu'ensemble en face les
70 derniers kilomètres ensemble ça ça
c'est le plan
chapitre 5 entrepreneur c'est vous qui
êtes au volant 12 août 2021
le départ a lieu demain je révise une
dernière fois ma stratégie
je me souviens me sentir extrêmement
bien
peu importe que la course est lieux ou
non les 6 mois de ma vie m'ont
transformé je ne suis plus le même gars
la destination qui a tant compté au
départ n'a plus d'importance le voyage
est magnifique
je vais donc me coucher serein et à 5h30
me voici sur la ligne de départ ça
ressemblait à ça avec un mot en tête
Théo on part doucement
alors je suis parti vite j'étais comme
un enfant à Noël quelle chance c'est
magnifique l'herbe est verte le ciel est
bleu les montagnes sont grandioses
j'arrive donc trop rapidement au sommet
de la Croix de Belledonne à 3000 mètres
d'altitude je fais cette photo tout
fringant je commence à descendre et là
et là déjà j'ai mal au ventre
11h30 du matin j'ai couru 35 km en 6
heures mes jambes sont fatiguées
j'arrive à un ravitaillement où les gens
font des expériences gastronomiques qui
trempent des biscuit sodas dans du
Coca-Cola et sans délecte mais les
visages sont déjà fatigués il fait chaud
une autre course commence à ce moment-là
je comprends que le but c'est pas
d'aller vite le but c'est d'aller au
bout un point c'est tout
je sais que mes parents m'attendent 10
km plus loin alors je repars
mes parents voient que c'est pas le même
Théo que c'est lui qui les a quitté ce
matin les coureurs prennent deux trois
trucs à manger et repartent mais moi je
m'arrête
je m'assois je mange avec mes parents on
discute et ils arrivent même à me faire
rire je repars 45 minutes plus tard les
jambes et le cœur soulagé
les kilomètres qui suivent se passent à
peu près bien je cours avec un groupe de
coureurs on soutient l'énergie est bonne
j'aurai découvre le paysage magnifique
8 heures du soir 65 km parcouru 14h 30
minutes de course
j'arrive au ravitaillement mis parcours
mes parents sont surpris de me voir
arriver en forme je me change waouh le
bonheur de mettre des vêtements secs
je mange un petit peu je mets ma lampe
frontale et je repars j'ai hâte de
retrouver mon frère 15 km plus tard
11h du soir 80 km parcourus 17h30 de
course ça y est je rejoins mon frère je
ne serai plus seul ça tombe bien il fait
nuit noir on m'a dit qu'il y avait des
loups dans les montagnes
on se serre dans les bras et on repart
sourire aux lèvres à l'assaut du col du
moretan
00h30 84 km parcourus 19 heures de
course il y a un petit point d'eau je
m'assois et demande à mon frère de
remplir mes gourdes et automatiquement
je tremble je frissonne je suis
frigorifié d'un coup je perds mon
enthousiasme et mal lucidité
la nuit on est même pas encore à la
moitié du col et déjà j'ai froid j'ai
faim j'ai peur
je doute
mon frère me tire on se remet à marcher
on monte mais dans ma tête c'est le
début de la descente aux enfers je suis
épuisé on arrive tant mieux que mal au
sommet du col il faut maintenant
redescendre dans la neige et les
cailloux la pleine lune nous éclaire
magnifique mais terrifiante
3h30 du matin
90 km de course
22h de mouvement
on avance pas 6 km en trois heures deux
kilomètres heure dans les derniers
kilomètres mon frère voit bien que
toutes mes pensées sont noires il sort
la technique ultime la playlist magique
mais même le Waka Waka de Shakira n'y
fait rien je veux juste faire une pause
une grande pause je parle juste de ça
j'étais motivé à faire cette course mais
à cet instant précis je ne sais plus du
tout ce que je fais là
la nuit noire ça fait 20 heures que je
cours je suis exténué physiquement
psychologiquement je n'ai plus de raison
de continuer et j'en veux à mon frère de
marcher en avant pourquoi on s'arrête
pas de dormir là
on fait un deal on va jusqu'au kilomètre
100 où nous attendent notre Crew et on
fait une longue pause on sait tous les
deux ce que je veux dire par une langue
pose dis jamais le mot abandonné mais
dans ma tête c'est tout ce à quoi je
pense
encore un pas
encore un pas je me répète toutes les
secondes pendant les deux prochaines
heures
5h30 du matin kilomètres 124 heures de
course ça y est je la vois la petite
tente blanche on arrive enfin au ravito
je m'assois
mon frère insiste déjà pour repartir et
notre deal alors mais il sait que si je
m'arrête c'est fini je repartirai pas je
parle plus dans ma tête les mêmes
affirmations tournent en boucle mais
qu'est-ce que tu pensais tu as pas ce
que ça prend pour cette course là tu es
un débutant Théo tout ce temps perdu à
t'entraîner tout ça pour abandonner
mes parents arrivent avec ma sœur vu ma
face ils sont d'accord avec moi il faut
qu'on prenne une pause on mange un
silence pas besoin de parler
ils comprennent ce qui s'est passé on
est vraiment en retard sur le temps et
physiquement j'ai pris 10 ans en 5
heures
ma sœur me prend par le bras et il
m'emmène dans la tente dortoir des leads
dans une tente elle me dit un spot c'est
libéré je te réveille dans 40 minutes
je m'endors instantanément 5 secondes
plus tard ça fait 40 minutes
je me lève tant bien que mal
je sors de la tente
le soleil aussi s'est levé
je sens sa chaleur et sa lumière sur mon
visage
je prends trois grandes respirations
ça y est ça y est je le sais
ça va être dur ça va être long mais je
vais finir cette course
chapitre 6 teens of training events
6h30 du soir 150 km parcourus 37 heures
de course on l'a fait on l'a fait on
franchit la ligne d'arrivée je reviens
pas quelle aventure
cet automne là je suis rentré au Québec
j'ai participé à plusieurs courses et
j'ai fini sur le podium de chacune
d'entre elles j'ai signé un contrat avec
une marque internationale et j'ai été
nominé parmi les trois espoirs du trail
québécois
faisons un résumé en prenant un peu de
hauteur chapitre 1 la seule façon
d'atteindre son objectif c'est de
s'aligner sur la ligne de départ et de
faire le premier pas chapitre 2 rêver
grand le rêve et ce qui alimente la
vision quand plus rien ne va c'est ce à
quoi on s'accroche chapitre 3 les
progrès c'est des efforts plus du repos
les meilleurs coureurs s'entraînent fort
mais ils se repose fort aussi chapitre 3
chapitre 4 les relations ce n'est pas
important les relations c'est tout
chapitre 4 chapitre 5 entrepreneur c'est
vous qui êtes au volant votre projet
votre responsabilité beaucoup veulent
vous aider vous tendre la main vous
donner des conseils à la fin de la
journée c'est votre décision votre
projet votre responsabilité
chapitre 6 ten year of triangle events
ça prend du temps du travail de la
passion des amis du plaisir un plan de
la chance beaucoup de persévérance pour
peut-être un jour atteindre son objectif
chapitre bonus connais-toi toi-même et
tu connaîtras l'univers et les dieux
lorsqu'on va au bout de soi même
lorsqu'on a plus rien c'est là qu'on se
rend compte de qui on est vraiment
ces instants rares font grandir et selon
moi sont les meilleurs diplômes qu'on
peut s'offrir
alors je vous invite à aller à la
rencontre de vous-même vous n'imaginez
sûrement pas tout ce dont vous êtes
capable
je suis donc convaincu qu'on a tous ce
qu'il faut pour entreprendre tout de
suite ce que ça prend c'est peut-être
juste un premier pas un ami un peu
craqué qui vous convainc de vous lancer
et je vois des entrepreneurs dans la
salle
vous montez votre montagne en ce moment
c'est difficile je sais
soyez doux avec vous-même et gardez en
tête qu'un entrepreneur devrait toujours
avoir de la place dans son agenda pour
une crème glacée entre amis
[Applaudissements]